there's an incredible you know like kind
of access point of like what you're
great at and what you love when you
stumble into being somebody like me you
really win when what you're naturally
great at is what you naturally love the
most and away you go
the amount of people that I meet every
day that I've graded something but have
no interest in being a CFO they love
them insane with numbers but they don't
want to do it they want to sing right or
you know like and so that's tough you
see it in athletics like people don't
understand athletes the amount of
athletes that just do it because it was
the best way in the same way that
somebody goes and becomes an accountant
and they don't love competition and they
don't love the sport it's crazy you know
when you look at them because you like
you're one of the 15 that you know and
they don't love it which is why they're
not the greatest athlete of all time the
greatest athletes of all time are the
ones who love it and have it and so I
think what you need to do is taste
everything it's kind of like food you
know what your favorite food is if you
only eat one food so I would take
advantage of your youth and and your
flexibility at this kind of age and try
to taste everything play with everything
figure out what you might be good at
what you might like and then you make a
decision
[Music]
Oh